Well, let's get going
then and welcome everybody
to the Data Science Hangout.
And a special welcome
to anyone who's
joining for the
first time today.
So if this is your first
time joining, just to let you
know how things work here.
It's an all audience
led informal session
where we want to focus
all of the data science
leadership questions that are
most important to you all.
And so each week I'm joined
by a different featured leader
you get to pick the brain of.
And so there's three ways
that you can ask questions.
You could jump in live,
you could put questions
in the chat, and we
also have a Slido, which
I'll share the link to shortly.
But just a reminder
that the conversation
is recorded and shared
up to YouTube for anybody
who misses it or if you want
to go back and check out
the recording.
But we really do want to make
this a open and welcome space
where everybody can participate.
And we really want to
hear from everyone.
And I'll say we
especially want to hear
from people from
underrepresented groups in data
science as well.
And I'm so excited to
be joined by my co-host
for today, Chase
Carpenter, Is the director
of strategy and analytics
at the Chicago Cubs.
And Chase, I'd
love to kick it off
by maybe having you
introduce yourself
and a little bit about
the work that you do.
Yeah.
Hey, Rachel.
Hey, everybody.
First off, sincere thanks for
scheduling this and giving me
the opportunity to chat today.
So as Rachel said, my
name is Chase Carpenter.
I'm the director of strategy and
analytics for the Chicago Cubs.
I've been with the organization
for just over five years.
Everything I work on is
on the business side.
And in a lot of
ways I support most
of our major functional areas.
So it's ticketing, marketing,
corporate partnerships,
food and beverage,
retail hospitality,
as well as our event
operations group.
We think of our--
I sit on our strategy team.
And so we think of
ourselves as, in a lot
of ways, an internal
resource or sort
of internal consulting group
for the rest of the business.
Awesome.
Thanks, Chase.
Well, thanks for joining us.
And while we're
waiting for questions
to come in from everyone,
I love to kick it off
with asking you maybe
what's something
that you're most excited about
with regards to data science?
Yeah, so it's a
really good question.
I spent some time
thinking about it.
I knew that would be
sort of front and center.
So I spend a lot
of my time trying
to think about how to drive
value out of data science,
and more broadly speaking,
sort of data as an asset.
And so I think even if you just
look at the my title, director
of strategy and
analytics, I spend a lot
of time trying to find
areas of opportunity
where we can drive business
value out of the data
that we have or that we
can reasonably go collect.
I think there's a wide
range of problems out there.
Some problems that
are interesting,
some problems drive
business value.
And so where I try
and focus my time
is sort of the
marriage of the two.
And I think more broadly for
data science as a profession,
we've made some awesome
progress better integrating
data and analytics into
the business operations,
certainly with them sports, but
across all industry verticals.
And so that's-- part of that
is due to tools and process.
And as well as at
the academic level,
some significant progress
in getting the right types
of course material into the
hands of students as they
come up through both
undergrad and graduate school.
And it's been an
awesome evolution
that we're actually seeing
this marriage of putting data
into practice so
that you can drive
business value for whatever
organization you're a part of.
Awesome.
And so for some of us who maybe
are thinking about Moneyball
as our first example of
how you use R in sports,
can you give us a
few examples of how
your team's using data
science on the business
side of the house?
Yeah, so when I
joined the organization,
my first title was assistant
director of advanced analytics.
And pretty much everyone thinks
that is Moneyball, right?
So it's like player
analytics, it's R&amp;D,
it's the book or the
movie, if you've seen that.
For better or worse,
I don't really
have any direct interaction with
our baseball operations team.
We've got a fantastic
R&amp;D group downstairs
that they do some
pretty awesome work.
On the business side,
a baseball team,
the majority of our revenue
and sort of our key business
really relates to ticketing.
We host 81 games a year.
And so there's a ton
of effort and emphasis
in thinking about
how do we match
the right product
with customers,
how do we drive demand
for our business.
And so a lot of the
problems that I worked on
are related to ticket
pricing, inventory management.
And then sort of the extension
of that is putting forward
a great guest experience.
So on a sold out
game, we'll have
38, 40,000 guests in our venue.
And so there's a big operation
to put forward the best guest
experience that we can.
And so there's a lot of
work behind the scenes
to really understand what do
our customers want, how can we
deliver products, and deliver
a guest experience that
meets their needs.
And so that's where I spend
a lot of my time trying
to improve or sort of evolve
what those products are
and what the game day
presentation looks like.
That's cool.
Can I ask you like,
what's an example
of a change to the
guest experience that
would come out of data science?
Yeah, so I think a lot-- so
the example I'd give really was
a byproduct of COVID, which
has been incredibly disruptive,
personally, professionally,
sort of across the board.
We were not able in 2020 to host
any guests at Wrigley Field.
We ended up being able to
play a shortened season.
But we took that downtime
as an organization
to ask some tough
questions on what
do we want the business to look
like in three to five years
because we kind of had this
extra window of time in which
we could plan and prepare.
And so from a game day
presentation and experience
standpoint, what
that turned into,
we completely overhauled
the access control process.
So historically, we'd
have these long lines
and you'd have to go
through this metal detector,
and it was just--
you'd have someone
poking in your bag.
It was not a very
welcoming experience.
And so through some new
technology and changes
that we deployed in
our security footprint,
we're able to completely
overhaul that entire process.
And once you get in the
venue, we put forward--
we moved cash from our
venue and put a big emphasis
on contactless ordering
for food and beverage.
Data science specifically played
into that in several components
because it's thinking about
balancing the guest experience.
There are certainly some
financial components
to some trade-offs
that we had to evaluate
in terms of staffing and
what we could actually
deliver to our guests.
But it is sort of data-- it
was a very data forward sort
of process, and understanding
the various stakeholders
and what's important
to each group,
and how do we find
the right balance.
Definitely.
And Chris, I didn't see
your question in the chat
when I brought up
Moneyball before.
Do you want to introduce
yourself and ask that question?
CHRIS: Oh, sure, why not?
So Chase, I'm a
data scientist here
at Air Force Special
Operations Command.
And the question that
I had posted on there
is just, how much influence
did the movie Moneyball have
on your job?
The short answer is a lot.
I wish that--
Sorry, were you going to
say something else, Chris?
CHRIS: Oh, no, I'm good.
OK.
The short answer is a lot.
I was fortunate enough to play
baseball through high school,
in college, and had big
aspirations to try and play
Minor League or Major
League Baseball,
and then to be a coach
or a scout or something.
For a variety of reasons
that didn't work out,
so I went into the
professional workforce.
Fast forward eight
or nine years and I
had the opportunity to
join the Cubs organization
on the business side.
And it was sort of
the perfect marriage
of what I had spent
being incredibly
passionate about for the
first 22 years of my life
and then married that with
where I had spent eight or nine
years on the professional side.
I am a huge, in my heart of
hearts, a huge baseball nerd
and so I still follow
FanGraphs and sort of all
the Moneyball type stuff.
And my personal
time doesn't play
as direct a role in what I
get to think about when I'm
wearing my official Cubs hat.
CHRIS: Wonderful, thank you.
Thanks, chase.
I see there's a few anonymous
questions coming in as well.
So I just want to head over
to some of those from Slido.
And the first one
was, how much do
the players know about analytics
and how it affects them?
You know, so I'd say,
first off, some of this
is a little bit of
speculation and more what
I've heard from my colleagues.
But I think really it runs
the gamut of some players
don't necessarily have much
appetite or interest in really
understanding the Moneyball type
metrics that we can produce.
On the other end
of the spectrum,
you get folks who sort
of live and breathe it.
And you've seen a
huge emphasis from all
the major front
offices in trying
to find ways to interject more
analytics into their decision
making, into their
player development,
and ultimately
trying to position
each player for success.
I think how that
actually manifests
on an individual player
level varies quite a bit.
Thank you.
Jeff, I see you just put a
question in the chat as well.
Would you want to
ask that one live?
Or I can read it.
Yeah, sorry, I'm on
baby duty right now.
Hey Chase, long time.
I was going to say,
long time no see, Jeff.
Good to see you.
Yeah, good to see you too.
I'm curious what the tech
stack looks like at the Cubs.
And is it different between--
I don't know the terminology
you're using-- but
like retail and professional?
Like the folks that are doing
the actual Moneyball stuff,
are they using a
different tech stack?
And how is that different
from what we were
doing seven or eight years ago?
Yeah, it's a
good question, and
awesome to see a friendly face.
Yeah, for context, Jeff
and I worked together
for five or six years.
And then we both gone
on our separate ways.
So briefly, so our tech
stack on the business side,
I think relatively standard.
We have a fairly robust data
warehouse infrastructure.
Currently, we're sitting
on an Oracle tech stack.
And we have-- our IT
team sort of formally
owns data ingestion,
all the ETL work.
They also own our business
intelligence layer.
So in a lot of ways,
I sit on top of that.
In my day-to-day, I have,
more specifically, RStudio
open pretty much
every single day.
I run most of my
analytical work through R.
On the baseball operations
side, to be honest,
we're almost two completely
separate companies.
I know they have a very
heavy R and Python base.
They're also do a lot of
internal custom app development
work.
And so there's more of an app
development focus in that group
as well, that
they're finding ways
to marry the analytics
coming out of R or Python,
and then embedding
those into applications
that they can push out
to coaches and players.
Thanks, Jeff,
for your question.
And I did just want to say
if anybody writes a question
and you don't want me to
have you read it out loud
or if you're in like a
loud cafe or something,
you could put like a
little star at the end
and then I'll know
to just read it too.
But Ronald, I saw that you
had also asked a question
in the chat earlier.
Can I give you the mic and have
you add some context there too?
RONALD: Yeah, sure.
I always like to
hear myself talk.
I am not a data analyst.
I just sort of play one at work.
My question has to do with
how are your projects or areas
of analysis determined.
And I ask that
because I find myself,
at least in this business,
working a little bit
with ad hoc where I have to
keep an eye on a lot of what
is going on in various
departments and area,
whether that's fiscal
or operations or patient
throughput or whatnot.
And I do get a certain
amount of guidance from,
oh, we have this
problem, solve it.
But yet it's people
who really have
no idea how to go about that.
So actually doing a very
in-depth scope of work analysis
becomes critical.
And I'm wondering what
sort of a situation
you've encountered there.
Yeah--
RONALD: And this is a
really generic question.
Just almost anybody
that I ask is like,
how does one do this optimally?
Or is there an optimal way?
That's a really good question.
And it's something I spent
a ton of time thinking
through conceptually when
I joined the organization.
I was the first dedicated
business analytics hire.
And so I was also
joining as a team of one,
so finite resource
in that respect.
I don't know if this
is best practice,
but what I ended up doing
is I essentially developed
three criteria and a
little checklist that
would allow me to have that
scoping exercise that you
referenced.
And really what that scoping
exercise boiled down to
is sort of, what's
the size of the prize
or what's the size
of the problem?
Two, do we actually
have data that
can help understand or
improve the problem?
And then three, when
does that-- when does
the work need to be done?
What's the timing?
And by focusing on
those three problems,
I've gotten pretty adept
at filtering projects that
are material enough
that sort of warrant
a significant
investment of time.
Two, that we can
actually influence
through thinking about
through a data science
or an analytical perspective.
And three, fits with
the business cadence.
And if you strikeout or can't
check all three of those boxes,
then you can just facilitate
the next conversation
of like, OK, I can't
directly help you,
but how can we
move this forward.
And candidly, particularly
when I initially joined,
you have some
uncomfortable conversations
because as a service function
and a support resource,
having to tell your colleagues
that I can't directly help you
or here's why this
may not be a good fit,
those are tough
conversations to have.
But I think necessary
conversations
that you can prioritize
your time on driving data
through business.
Thanks, Chase.
And Libby, I see you just
asked a question in the chat
as well, if you want to
jump in and ask that one.
Sure.
Yeah, I was wondering about
dynamic, like real-time dynamic
pricing models for tickets.
That's something that I've
always been really interested
in as a person who does
like optimization and stuff
like that.
But I don't know how
widespread that actually is.
And I was wondering
how the pandemic
might have shifted some of
those models for sports teams.
Yeah, so dynamic
pricing, it's a big topic
and a huge area of focus.
As an organization, I believe we
began adopting dynamic pricing
in 2011 or 2012.
So we've got roughly a decade
sort of under our belt.
I will say I would draw a big
distinction in how we think
about dynamic pricing
versus someone
like a leading e-commerce
store, someone like Amazon
where they've got
millions of SKUs
and they have some
humans behind the scenes,
but they've deployed
machine learning
models to sort of
algorithmically price
and manipulate prices in a
somewhat automated fashion.
We're not that hands-off.
So behind the scenes there's
a collaboration between myself
and our ticketing colleagues.
And we're, essentially
in real time,
always monitoring and observing
demand as it materializes.
We have some
analytical models that
help us make some estimates
on how we may change price.
But it is a little more manual
and hands on than, at least
in an academic
setting, when you think
about this is the
optimal dynamic pricing
infrastructure where we've got
some real headroom to sort of
grow into that type of model.
I think that's great.
Thank you.
Yeah, I think keeping
the human in the loop,
like the algorithm loop,
is really interesting.
And also kind of the
algorithm aversion
that you might see
where you're like,
oh, I don't think that's
the right thing to do.
I don't want the computer
to make the decision for me.
That's been an
interesting topic.
And I think that it's great that
you guys use it as a reference
and not as something
that's automatic.
Yeah, so part
of this, I think,
is the sports
industry write our--
there's two dynamics that
sort of distinguish us
from a lot of other dynamic
pricing applications.
One, we have finite inventory.
Got 41,000 seats per event.
And two, that inventory
expires and becomes perishable.
So I can't sell the ticket
to last Tuesday's game.
And then the third part of
that is, in addition, we
have multiple sales channels.
And so accurately, you can
get some interesting signals
in your data that may or
may not actually correlate
to an increase or
decrease in demand.
So for example, a large
group ticket order,
if there is a church
group or some--
we may sell a chunk
of 500 tickets.
Without some proper
treatment and sort
of nuanced understanding
of how that data actually
flows through our
systems, you could
make the naive interpretation
of demand is through the roof.
Don't change price.
And that may or may
not actually have
anything to do with
the underlying demand.
It's just like when a group
sale goes through, for example.
I have a similar
question to Robert,
who just put in the chat,
should we use incognito mode
when purchasing sports tickets?
I've always wondered
that for concerts.
I mean, I would say this
is more my personal bias.
I mean, you should
probably use incognito
for most of the things that
you do on the internet.
And I would say that probably
extends to purchasing sports
tickets.
No, I mean, I think both through
our official primary channel,
you know forbes.com/tickets, we
have a decently robust ad tech
stack behind the scenes that
will allow us to sort of track
your behavior to some extent
and then show you relevant ads
or sort of follow up to that.
You'll certainly, if you look at
the secondary market, StubHub,
Vivid, [INAUDIBLE],,
those organizations
have very robust ad
tech stacks that I'm
somewhat envious
of because that's
central to the success
of their business.
And they've made the
necessary investments.
So can you tell us like
buy tickets x days before?
Just kidding.
No, I mean, that's
an interesting one.
People do-- we have seen
a huge shift of people
delaying their purchase
closer and closer to events.
And so that's a consumer
behavior phenomenon
that we're seeing across
all sorts of industries.
I think that creates a
risk for us as a business,
going back to my point
related to expiring inventory.
So as sales get pushed closer
and closer to the event date,
that just creates more
uncertainty for our business,
and where we spend a lot
of time thinking about
how do we operate
in this environment
that we're watching unfold.
Right.
I see an anonymous
question that just
came in that was, since
sports games happened
so frequently, how are models
and analytical projects
evaluated over what time period?
It's highly context specific.
In baseball, there's
a couple of lenses
that most of our decisions
sort of naturally fall into.
One is a yearly cadence.
To some extent, the
baseball schedule
is pretty much sentence
set in stone from April 1
to end of September.
And so a lot of the work that we
do, the true and sort of final
evaluation for success
certainly sort of materializes
throughout the season.
But the real evaluation is
after the season has unfolded.
More at the operational
level, there
is success that can be
evaluated and changes actually
put in practice, sometimes
on a game to game basis,
but more often than not, a
home stand by home stand basis.
And so it's roughly
every other week.
So we can make
operational changes.
The team goes away for 10
days and then they come back,
and so we can make some
changes in between home stands.
Thank you.
Mubanga, I see you had,
I think, a follow-up
question maybe to what
Libby had asked earlier.
Would you want to
jump in and ask that?
Or we can get back
to that one after.
I wasn't sure how to summarize
the question in there.
But I see there's also an
anonymous question for you,
Chase that was--
Sorry, Rachel, I was on mute.
It was basically a comment
based on what Chase explained
in reaction to Libby's
question because I was just
thinking to myself, because
the pricing is dynamic
so it means that the system is
changing continuously in time.
So I've seen applications before
where reinforcement learning
has been used in--
it's not exactly
the same setting,
but in settings like that, like
self-driving cars for example.
So I was just wondering to
myself, what kind of algorithm
they use at the Cubs?
So I would say--
so specific to
dynamic pricing, we
have tested a wide range
of different algorithms
and sort of decision frameworks.
Everything from your sort
of traditional, classic
regression-based models
to non-parametric models.
Jeff and I, in our prior life,
worked at a consulting shop
that specialized in a variety
of Bayesian techniques
and so I've sort of
messed around and tried
to make sort of the
Bayesian frameworks fit
within the type of
data that we have.
I will say, having spent a fair
amount of time in that area,
I think the bigger challenge
that we have is more
at the data synthesis
and aggregation layer,
getting the various data
sets that you would want
in real time or sort of at the
right granularity or frequency
that we ideally want
to make decisions.
We run into more
bottlenecks at that
layer versus any
individual algorithm
will end up being somewhat
performant given the data
constraints that we have.
So I spend more of my
time focused at, how
can I go get the incremental
data at a more fine granularity
so that we can sort
of more meaningfully
engage in more of the sort of
true optimization, algorithm
optimization.
Thanks, chase.
I see Jeff asked another
question in the chat that was,
is there any animosity
between the Cubs and resellers
like Ticketmaster?
It's a good question.
So in the ticket
distribution space,
you've got a couple
different entities.
You have us as the Cubs and we
sell on our own channels that
you go to the box office, you
can call a telephone number,
cubs.com/tickets.
Then you have the
secondary markets.
But you also have the--
different terms are used-- but
brokers are essentially people
who are in the business of
acquiring inventory from us
and then selling those
tickets in a variety--
through a variety of channels.
I think there is some
healthy tension that
can arise because the incentives
that each of those parties
may not always align
with one another.
And so in general, I
think our incentives
are pretty aligned with the
secondary changers themselves.
We want to have sort of the
broadest distribution pipes
that we can and get our
tickets in front of people
wherever they are and however
they want to purchase.
Those exchanges, they're
obviously interested in helping
to sell Cubs tickets.
But they have a huge portfolio
of live event inventory
that they also care about.
So there's just--
I don't think we've
perfected the business
model or the
relationships between all
of the various parties.
But in general, we work
pretty well together.
Thank you.
And apologies, my audio just got
a little cut out for a second.
So let me know if it
sounds weird to anyone.
But I think I missed a
question earlier, Sep,
that you had asked.
And sorry if I've missed any
other questions earlier too.
But can I pass the mic
over to you for that one?
Yeah, sure.
So I think you would
refer to your--
someone asked a question
about your tech stack earlier.
But I kind of
wanted to understand
a little bit of that last
mile of how you deliver
your results to the business.
Yeah, so I'd say
a couple avenues.
We build and maintain
a small number
of Shiny applications, which
ends up being the deliverable.
A fair number of outputs
will be injected back
into our data warehouse and then
rendered through our BI layer.
But also, I will admit,
at least for our business,
a lot of my counterparts
across the organization
still rely pretty
heavily on, effectively,
the Microsoft stacks; it's
Excel, it's PowerPoint,
it's Word.
And it's been a big
ambition of mine
to get away from that mindset.
But it's a real reality.
And part of it is a
lot of the outputs
that we generate make their
way into other source documents
or deliverables that I
don't own or sort of have
much purview into.
Certainly collaborative
like board materials,
if we're putting a board
deck or a memo together,
need to provide
deliverables that
can easily be dropped and
live in those documents.
Thanks.
Can I dive a bit
deeper there because I'm
sure that a bunch of
people on the call
have that struggle as well.
How are you going about
trying to change that
or like working to
gather the team?
I'm not sure I
have a great answer.
I think, internally, I am
making a conscious effort
to shift more and more
of our deliverables
into more reproducible, R
Markdown, or just sort of fully
contained scripts and
processes and then
sort of go kicking
and screaming when
we need to break that paradigm.
But it's a constant sort
of tension or something
that we're always evaluating.
So with R Markdown
does the team also
generate PowerPoint or
Word from R Markdown too?
I tried, to be honest, given--
and this is sort of in the
weeds on the specific formats.
And for the preferences that
we have in those templates,
I haven't been able
to fully close the gap
and get 100% continuity there.
I'm sure it could be done.
It's more of a timing
and resourcing thing.
Yeah, that's something I
hear a lot from like the Excel
reports perspective too, like
around certain formatting.
Tatiana, I see you had
a question you just
asked in the chat as well.
Would you want to
ask that one live?
Sure.
So you did mention,
Chase, that you
deal with ambiguity
and uncertainty a lot.
So I'd be curious to hear what
are your most go-to techniques
for approaching ambiguity.
And where you basically
stop and say, hey,
this is the threshold where
I'm about to accept it
and I'm not going
to dig further?
And the second question was
just about your journey.
Since you started on as
a one man department,
how did your role evolve?
And what aspect
did you enjoy most?
From business analysis
to data science,
it seems like you're more
into data science right now,
and I'm curious to
hear how it started.
Yeah, both good questions.
I'll try-- I'll
take them in order.
So in thinking
about uncertainty,
I think as an organization--
I think there's two
questions-- there are two
questions embedded in there.
One is more the
mechanically, how
do you think about and actually
quantify the uncertainty
from an analytical perspective?
And I'd go back to a lot
of the Bayesian frameworks
that I was introduced
to in my first job
or they've just got some nice
academically rigorous and just
like conceptually sound
managers to actually think
about confidence intervals
or credible intervals.
And so I use those frameworks
sort of mechanically.
I think where I have
spent a lot of time
is getting my colleagues
and counterparts
in our organization
comfortable with embracing
that uncertainty.
A lot of the areas
where I spend my time,
we have to-- our
analytical deliverables are
do several weeks or months
in advance of those events
actually happening.
And to sit here in the
first week of November
and with 100% specificity
say, here's my projection
for the ticket sales next
July, it's really hard
to make that argument.
But I've spent a lot of time
getting our organization
to understand, like here's the
range of probable outcomes.
Here are the things
that would make
us believe that we may
over-index or sort of
underperform.
And how much risk or uncertainty
are we willing to accept?
And what's the downside
of if we misproject
or basically what's the
cost of being wrong?
And that's taken the better
part of my five years
here to get folks
to fully embrace.
COVID-19 was somewhat
beneficial in that
because we had so
much uncertainty
facing our business.
That uncertainty, it
was front and center.
And there was no other way,
at least in my opinion,
to like reasonably think about
what may happen in our business
than through sort of a
truly probabilistic manner.
I'm sorry.
Your second question
was more on--
And on how your role
basically evolved.
But going back to
uncertainty for a second.
So you basically, you
first built out your model,
and then you accept
stakeholders?
So you consult them on
what level of uncertainty
they're willing to accept?
Or do you set it beforehand
and you have a conversation,
like, here's my data.
Here's how far we can go.
And here's the levels of
uncertainty we can dig into.
Is that a conversation
you have beforehand
or after you build your model?
Or it depends?
To some extent, it depends.
Before materially
engaging with colleagues,
I try and sort of push
the analytical models
as far as we can.
So I have an understanding
on here's how much
sort of statistical
power, how confident we
can be in these results.
And then also framing
up we are getting
into the grounds
of like, we don't
have specific enough data.
Or there's just
more uncertainty.
We're sort of crossing
a threshold of we're
asking for precision that this
model can't really support.
So let's take a step back
and sort of understand
what those limits are.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah, kind of does.
Because it's hard to answer
a big question, right?
So yeah.
And the second question
was about just your role,
how it evolved.
I assume that since you were
the first person, right,
as far as I understand it
in your analytics department
in your company,
how much did you
have to spend on the buy in, and
business analysis, et cetera?
Or if the stage the company was
in when you joined them was I
guess cognizant enough
of the processes,
so you didn't have to
spend a lot of time
on educating I guess?
And which aspect did you enjoy
most as your role evolved?
Yeah, when I joined,
the organization
had recognized the need to
bring on some more resources
and in the business
analytics area.
So there was a little
bit of initial buy-in
that had already occurred that
led to my role being created.
Having said that,
in any organization,
you're ultimately building
relationships with individuals.
And so I was pretty conscious
in finding some quick wins,
and sort of early
victories that I
could find to gain
that credibility,
so that we could grow
into bigger, more complex,
and challenging problems.
When I joined, I'd say
most of the problems
that I initially worked on
in the first 12 to 18 months
were sort of pretty
pure point analytics.
Like, the problems are
well-defined and scoped.
There's a clear
analytical angle that we
could bring to the table,
but it was pretty well boxed.
As I have progressed
through my five years here,
more and more of the
work that I spend
on where I spend my
time now is addressing
bigger, strategic issues for
the organization, and sort
of somewhat major sort
of policy decisions
that we are evaluating.
And I certainly own, and sort of
bring the consumer and the data
perspective to the table.
But there are very real sort
of non-quantitative other
stakeholders, and
other considerations
that as an organization
we need to evaluate.
And we have a very large media
presence as an organization.
And so we're very
conscious of the messages
that we put into the market,
and sort of our standing
just from a PR standpoint.
I've not figured out
how to weave that
into my analytical models.
But it's a very
real consideration
that it's more of an open
discussion and dialogue
with my colleagues.
Thank you.
I see Robert had
also asked earlier,
what does collaboration look
like with various vendors
that the Cubs uses?
And then Libby kind of had a
plus one to that that asks,
are vendors connected in any way
as far as data sharing, like,
from a connected supply
chain perspective?
So I guess--
Libby, do you mind
helping me understand
the second part of your question
in a little bit more detail?
I could go in a couple of
different directions here.
LIBBY: Sure.
So I was wondering
if the Cubs have
visibility into the data
of suppliers or vendors?
And if that goes the
other direction as well,
if it's even present?
I guess-- sorry, I
keep diving in here.
Are you thinking
sort of specifically
in consumer type data, or more
other operational business data
that we need to create?
LIBBY: So I would
say a little bit
of both, whether
that's information
about your consumers that are
coming from vendors who might
be servicing ticket
sales, or if it's
more of a supply type thing,
where you guys have business
suppliers.
Do they have visibility
into your supply chain?
Or do you have visibility
upstream or downstream
in that sort of
sense of the word?
Yeah, OK.
Thank you, super helpful.
So I guess a couple
parts of that,
the main driver of customer
data are ticket sales.
So we have sort of
complete visibility
into the ticket sale process.
Four or five years ago, we began
delivering all of our tickets
mobily.
So you can no longer
print a ticket.
You don't get a
hard stack ticket.
You can't do the print
a PDF thing anymore.
So through that, we are
generating a lot of data.
So now, we get
ticket forward data.
And so we get more
insight into sort of who
is actually attending a game.
And the next evolution
of that that we
unrolled for 2020
rollout is through
our global ordering footprint.
Now, we can actually
tie individual--
now, we've got pretty good
insight into the ticket data.
Now, for the people who leverage
our mobile ordering platform,
now I can actually start to
understand food and beverage
preferences about that
individual which we've never
had insight into before.
Historically, you'd go
to the concession stand,
you'd buy whatever you buy.
We'd get like the last
four of the credit card,
but no meaningful way to tie
that back to any individual.
So that's been sort of
the main sources of data.
We also our own WiFi deployment,
so we generate some customer
data there.
We do have-- obviously,
we have a decent footprint
in terms of digital spend across
the social media websites.
And so we kind of
fit into probably
they're like small
medium business category.
But we have active engagement
and collaboration with them
to improve our marketing
operations basically.
Thanks, Chase.
I know that some of the
R in sports analytics
meet-ups a lot of people have
questions around how to get
that first job in sports.
I'm curious to hear your
perspective there on maybe
how you did that, or how you'd
advise others to go about that.
So I think finding
the first job in sports
is often the most
challenging one.
I think once you've found
a foothold, particularly
on the business side,
it's pretty open
and sort of
collaborative community.
And so you see a fair
amount of not job hopping,
but you can sort of navigate
the professional team landscape
somewhat.
I won't say usually, but
it happens quite a bit.
In terms of putting
together a strategy
to land that first
job in sports,
I'd highlight a
couple of things.
One, I go back to sort
of where I started.
If your preference
and priority is
to work in sort of a baseball,
or the player operations
side of the house, there's
a pretty clear path
that developing some
expertise in being incredibly
smart, and sophisticated,
and understanding
player performance.
On the business side,
at least for me,
I had really no understanding
of how the business of baseball
worked before I got
into the business.
But there's some good
publicly available resources
for not only baseball,
but all the major sports.
Forbes does a really good job
of just synthesizing here's
how the business side of
these operations work.
And so I spent some
time just level
setting, and really
understanding
how businesses operate.
The second focus I have is, you
need to get a little scrappy
and tap into your
network, and find
friends, or friends of
friends, reach out on LinkedIn.
Or if you Google Cubs front
office, or any team front
office, you'll in general, find
a whole roster of employees.
So look at the job descriptions.
Look at the titles.
Look at the individuals.
Reach out, and start to
build some connections.
The third one is, be patient.
All front offices are smaller
than maybe most people
would think.
And so jobs don't
have necessarily
had a predictable
hiring cadence.
And so be patient
and do some diligence
to figure out when jobs
do become available.
And the last thing
I'd highlight is,
if your heart is set on
working for a front office,
I'm certainly not going to tell
you to not go down that path.
But there are some
awesome jobs available.
And when I say the front
office, adjacent industries,
the major concessionaires
all employ
but hundreds of analytics
focused professionals.
There's a great sort of
cottage industry of consultants
that focus on the sports space.
So depending on your
preferences and priorities,
you can land a job in any
number of sport adjacent areas.
So the last thing I'll say is,
it's a little bit self-serving
here.
But I am looking to add a
couple of folks to my team.
We got one job
description up right now,
and another will be up shortly.
So if anyone's interested
in focusing on improving
the business operations,
cubs.com/jobs.
And there, we've got
some opportunities
available on our team.
Awesome.
Something that might be helpful
to dive into deeper here,
and maybe with the
whole group as well
is, when we talk about
being able to find
these opportunities
and networking.
I wonder how finding a
diverse pool of candidates
also plays into that.
And what are some of the things
that your organization does?
Yeah.
It's a challenge.
We're making a very conscious
effort to try and raise
the brand awareness and profile
of our organization to groups
who may not otherwise
naturally find cubs.com/jobs.
The tactics on how
you execute that
are somewhat specific
to the individual roles.
But it's a big emphasis
and priority for us
as an organization
that I think we had--
it's just an area that we
can get better and evolve.
And so it's making
conscious efforts
to increase sort of
the top of the funnel,
how do we raise our brand
awareness and footprint,
so that we can attract a more
qualified and diverse group
of candidates.
It's something that we're
spending a lot of time trying
to evolving it better at.
That's great.
Thank you.
I see there was another
anonymous question
earlier that asked about
what you originally studied.
Was it analytics?
Or how did you get
into this space?
So my undergrad work
focused on political science
and psychology, so not terribly
heavy on the data analytics
front.
My first job, I feel like I got
the equivalent of a master's
in applied statistics, a
lot of on the job training.
I supplemented that with
some graduate coursework
in statistics.
And then I went back
and did my MBA part time
with a focus on operations,
analytics, and marketing.
But I think most of my practical
what I use in my day-to-day
really came from my first job.
And are there-- so are
there certain skills that
you're hiring for right
now, or certain things that
you're looking for
for those open roles?
I would say, yes.
So one, we're looking to bring
on a pricing analyst, someone
to help us get smarter
on all the things
that we talked about previously
with respect to pricing.
And the second role is more
database marketing and sales
operations focused.
I think in terms
of skills, I think
I need someone to be successful
in these roles in particular--
and I think this does apply
to a lot of analytics focused
roles in sports-- is you need
to be comfortable with wearing
a couple of different hats.
I am not a database
engineer by trade.
But nonetheless, unlike working
at a big tech company where
you've got seemingly
unlimited resources,
and people can get
incredibly hyper focused
and specific on very
interesting and niche problems,
we need someone who is a little
bit more of a generalist,
and comfortable wearing a
couple of different hats.
And so people who have
background in statistics,
or who have sat in the chair
at another company sport
adjacent is super helpful.
I think the other thing
that interesting contrast
between my first
role as a consultant,
and what I in my
current chair is,
I get to sort of wear
the consulting hat.
But we're also the operator.
And so there is a
much bigger emphasis
and focus on practical analytics
that we can actually deploy.
Whereas, at least in my
previous role as a consultant,
we had to do all this
super interesting and fun
analytical work.
But ultimately, you kind of
hand that over to the client,
and you go on to
the next project.
We have the burden of
actually putting into practice
what we build.
And so having more of the
mindset, and sort of wanting
to take ownership of the full
analytical process end to end,
which is a little bit
different than when
at least when I
went through school.
There wasn't a ton of focus
on that last part of like how
do you actually move
the business forward
through the application
of analytics.
Yeah.
Russ, I see you just
asked a question.
I'd love to turn that
over to you to ask live.
Yeah.
Thanks, Rachael.
Chase, love the content so far.
One thing that affects
a lot of us that
work in financial services,
are systematic shifts in data,
right?
So think about something
like COVID, right?
Drastically affected
consumer buying behavior.
And it really wasn't something
we had seen historically
in our data lakes and
data warehouses, right?
So certainly complicated my
job, and my team's job a lot.
Because a lot of our models were
misfiring pretty badly, right?
And I think sports
analytics has always
been something that's been
very interesting to me.
Like full disclosure, Cleveland
Indians fan, or Guardians fan.
So I still haven't
gotten over 2016 yet.
You know, I've been fascinated
by ESPN'S FPI, and some
of the stuff they do
in Georgia Tech related
to college basketball.
But I'm thinking about
specifically with the Cubs,
right, and sort of like
the transitional state
they're in in the
organization, specifically you
know, trading away
Schwarber and Baez,
and you know, I forget
the gentleman who
went to San Francisco.
But I would have to
imagine that's going
to make a lot of
your historical data
a little less useful
for you and your team.
Do you have any
tips or strategies?
Or have you guys started
digging into this,
and seeing what you can
do to make your maybe
previous models better
fitting for the new reality
you guys are going to be in?
Yeah, that's a great question.
You sort of hit on
the fundamental crux
of what I think it means
to sit on the business
side of a sports organization.
So in an abstract
sense, all teams--
sports are cyclical
by nature, right?
And that's due to a
variety of reasons,
mostly a lot of its team
performance related.
Our job on the business
side is to smooth out
those natural team
performance cycles.
And when team performance
is really good,
our job is to push
the business forward.
And then when team
performance takes a step back,
like we just saw at the
most recent trade deadline,
it's to sort of
mitigate the loss,
or don't let the
floor go as low.
And so our job is to mitigate
sort of that natural team
performance cycle and
move the business forward
somewhat independent
of where we're
at in any given
team performance,
or competitive dynamic cycle.
That's the abstract answer.
And that's my guiding
light, and how
I think about how I can
impact the business.
More mechanically
to your point, we
are in a drastically
different demand environment,
and just sort of team
performance cycle
today than we were
even four months ago.
What I have done from a
practical standpoint is,
we have pretty good
historical data.
And if you go back to
2010, '11, '12, '13, '14,
the Cubs were not
terribly competitive.
And so what we have done is
put a little bit more emphasis
on more further back in time,
but data and demand profiles
that is a little bit more
representative of where
we can reasonably expect
team performance to be moving
forward.
So just think from like a
weighting standpoint, or just
the types of data
that we emphasize
in training our models,
I'll say to some extent,
we do try to directly
incorporate some team
performance dynamic
elements into our models,
whether that's expected wins,
or playoff probabilities.
There's somewhat
easy things that we
can calculate that we can
sort of update over time.
But it's a hard problem.
Yep.
Definitely.
Thank you.
I see Ronald asked
a great question.
And I think he had to
drop to another meeting.
So I'm just going to read it.
But earlier when we were talking
about presenting deliverables,
you mentioned Markdown,
or Markdown and Shiny.
The question was, to
what extent is leadership
able to process
this information?
Or do you guide leadership
through the results?
Along those lines, you're
providing presumably
much deeper information than
the PowerPoint, Excel crowd.
And how is this different
perceived by leadership?
I think my best
answer to that would
be, it's highly
specific based on
the individual characteristics
of those individuals.
And we sort of have
the full gamut of--
my direct boss loves
to get into the weeds.
He wants to understand
why did you choose
this algorithm versus that.
What happens if you
change these assumptions?
And so we spend a lot of
time looking at an R-script,
and like, here's
conceptually what's going on.
And like, here's
the relative impact
of these different assumptions.
My boss sort of over indexes
on that side of things.
On the other side, you've got
other individuals who don't--
not they don't
have the appetite--
but they're more focused
on the business outcome.
And it's been somewhat
of an iterative process
to understand what
resonates to what audience,
and tailoring and catering
those deliverables
to those individuals.
Thank you.
Libby, I also think you had
a question earlier around
the biggest false assumptions
that people generally make.
Do you want to add any
context to that one?
LIBBY: I think that
I've just been thinking
a lot about assumptions
lately, and how I'm usually
wrong when I make
assumptions about how
other organizations or
even individuals use data,
and the level of complexity
that they actually use that,
and the application areas.
So sports is something
I'm not familiar with.
And I would like to ask what
the biggest assumption is
that people make that's
just totally wrong?
Somewhat tongue in
cheek, but the question
I still feel from friends,
family people I meet is like,
am I hanging out
in the clubhouse
and having dinner
with their players?
And that's like could not
be farther from the truth.
You know, all those guys they're
kind of doing their own thing.
But I think sort more
directly to your point
on assumptions about our
core business operations,
I think people have a lot
of assumptions about where
decisions are made, and
sort of who is running
the show to some extent.
And pretty much all of
your major sports teams
are in some capacity owned
by private ownership group.
And those owners have different
media personalities themselves,
and individual,
and family brands.
That depending on
the organization,
they may or may
not have anything
to do with the
day-to-day operations.
But nonetheless, if you follow
Twitter, sort of major media
outlets, the characterization
of the decision making process
as it gets described
by the media
is often pretty far from what I
observe on a day-to-day basis.
And by and large, it's
one of those things
that we're not really
equipped, or would necessarily
be in our best interest to try
and change those perceptions.
So we just kind of shrug
your shoulders and go on.
But it's interesting
seeing how stuff
that I am directly involved
in behind the scenes
ends up getting
portrayed in the media.
And sometimes, it's spot on.
And other times, you're
just kind of like,
that's not how this works.
Thank you, Chase.
As we get to the
top of the hour,
I know some people
might have to run.
So I just want to
ask, what's the best
way to get in touch with
you if people have follow up
questions, or if they're
interested in any of the roles?
Is it LinkedIn?
Yeah, I'm pretty easy
to track down on LinkedIn.
So I please encourage anyone to
reach out via LinkedIn if you
have any questions specific to
the role certainly, but more
generally, if you
have an interest,
or just want to learn more
about the sports industry.
I obviously know the
most about baseball,
but have some decent perspective
on other leagues as well.
But yeah, please do reach out.
And I'm usually pretty
good about responding.
Awesome.
Thank you, Chase.
If it's OK, can I ask you
maybe one or two more questions
as we--
I just want to make
sure I didn't miss any.
I'd love to hear what advice
you have for maybe someone who's
on the call right now that's
hoping to get into a leadership
position, and how
they could move
from being that individual
contributor into leadership?
I feel like the biggest
jump there, it's probably not
in the hard skills category.
I think in order to
move up, I sort of
think of the hard
skill, you know,
the proficiency and
excellence in what I think
is like the hard data science
type skills, that's somewhat
of a table stakes criteria.
So you need to show a sort of
minimum level of competency,
or excellence in that category.
But where I think you can
start to differentiate
yourself is more
in the soft skills.
It's the leadership.
It's the negotiation.
It's the team building.
It's sort of all the stuff
that can be described
as like the soft fluffy skills.
But when you think about--
I think high-performing
organizations have tightly
aligned strategy and
data analytics functions.
And so when I think about
what does aspiring leader need
to do, it's starting
to develop a knack
for what is the strategy
of the organization,
and how can I influence that?
Data, in a lot of ways is a
tool that can very meaningfully
improve organizations,
but I think
you can really
differentiate yourself
on outperforming your
competitors in some sense,
in those soft skills.
Thank you, Chase.
And I just want to say, if I've
missed anybody's questions,
I'm trying to [INAUDIBLE]
in the chat here.
But please feel free to
just unmute yourself,
and jump in live too.
I'll do a quick check.
I don't see anyone that unmuted.
One last question, Chase,
I'd love to ask you.
I'm trying to help bring
more resources together
for someone who's just
trying to start advocating
for data science internally.
And maybe they're the
first data person.
How would you I guess, tell
someone to go about that
process if they're in a position
where they actually just
have to start at getting
approval to even use
some of these tools?
Yeah, I think where
my head initially goes--
and this goes back to
some of my MBA classes--
but I think it's a
pretty simple framework
of what's the ROI that you think
you could reasonably drive.
So I would think
about it as engaging
with sort of the
major stakeholders
in an organization,
and understanding
what are your
problems, and basically
how you think about it in terms
of revenue, or just efficiency,
right?
If this business unit is
operating at 80% efficiency,
what does it mean
to the business
if we can move
that to 85% or 90%?
Think about some way
to quantify that.
Balance that up
against what resources
you need to bring to the
table to unlock that 5% or 10%
improvement.
I think about that
in the broadest
sense of its headcount.
Its technology.
Its investment and
data warehousing.
Sort of depending on where that
organization is, that could
go in a lot of different ways.
But for my group, we think
about driving essentially,
a 5x return on the investments
that the organization make
in our group.
And that's sort of the
benchmark and the threshold
that I'm held accountable to.
It's worked well here.
And I think it's a good
sort of forcing function
to make sure you're focusing
your time on the right problems
that can sort of meaningfully
drive the business forward.
Definitely.
Thank you so much, Chase.
I really appreciate you
joining and jumping on here,
and sharing all your
insights with us.
I hope to get everybody together
in person at some point too.
And I know we talked
about maybe next year
there's the Sloan
Conference, Sports Analytics
conference in Boston,
maybe planning
a meetup or something
around that,
as well if other people are
going to be in the area.
But thank you so much.
Really appreciate it.
Yeah.
Thank you, Rachael.
And thanks, everyone.
Great questions
and dialogue today.
I really enjoyed it.
So thank you all.
Have a great rest
of the day, everyone.